[Music]
what happened at the end of reacher
season one what does that final scene
mean and what's going to happen in the
show's forthcoming second season keep
watching as we dive right in
for over 20 years readers worldwide have
been enthralled by lead child's book
series about the exploits of
larger-than-life protagonist jack
reacher after 26 novels the character
finally hit the small screen with the
amazon prime original reacher after two
feature films starring tom cruise amazon
studios rebooted the series with alan
richson in the titular role the series
also stars malcolm goodwin as detective
oscar finley and willow fitzgerald is
roscoe the first season runs for eight
episodes and is based on the first novel
of lee child's series killing floor jack
reacher gets off a bus in margrave
georgia only to be arrested immediately
for murder ultimately discovered not to
be involved in the murder he decides to
help with the investigation when more
victims appear including his brother the
small town of margrave is unwelcome to
outsiders including the black lead
detective finley who transferred down
from boston to escape his life in new
england partnered with a young officer
roscoe the trio investigates the murders
continuing to pile up leading them to a
powerful businessman a corrupt federal
agent and even the mayor sitting on the
steps of a gazebo when all is said and
done reacher says he will be moving on
he isn't one to stay rooted in one place
but what did this ending mean and what
is next for reacher
it's just who i am
at the beginning of the season reacher
was ready to leave the murders in
finley's hands and move on but was
forced to stay he only takes on a more
active role in the investigation when he
discovers his brother is a victim
however in the last few moments of the
season a flashback shows reacher and his
brother joe at the bedside of their
dying mother it's revealed that when
they were younger the brothers got into
a fight with a bigger kid joe took the
fall but their mother tells them she
always knew it was jack
he protected a weaker boy because that
was his nature and when reacher ended up
in margrave his mission started his
revenge but along the way his nature led
him to protect someone new the end of
the season sees reacher face the death
of his last family member it's not just
reacher who faces up to his past
throughout the season roscoe also comes
to terms with her legacy during the
season she reveals that the teal family
were rivals of her own family the
conklins in the final minutes of the
warehouse battle she takes out mayor
teal for his part in the criminal
organization and reacher suggests that
she should run for mayor which would
return the town to its rightful place as
we said before finley isn't from
margrave but relocated there to get away
from boston at the beginning of the
season reacher mistakenly pegs the
detective as a divorced man but later
finley reveals he is a widower
in his final scene with reacher he
informs him he is quitting police work
and heads home to move on with his life
reacher isn't a man who likes to stick
around much of his character and story
arc is predicated on him being in a new
place and finding himself in a brand new
form of trouble that means there are 25
more books they could have chosen from
for season two however to stick out as
the best possible options for a
follow-up season since season one began
the jack reacher story on screen with
lee child's first book about the
detective it isn't far-fetched to expect
amazon to next adapt the second book in
the series die trying on the other hand
the series introduces someone from
reacher's past that they can build on
francis neely is a pi and a former
member of reacher's special
investigations unit in the army during
one episode after the pair is attacked
they utter a line which is used in the
summary of the 11th book of the series
bad luck and trouble you do not mess
with the special investigators
of course this could just be
coincidental either way there are dozens
of potential storylines in the novels to
pull from and with alan richton at the
perfect age to keep going amazon could
have a hit series that go on for a
decade or even longer check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
tv shows are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]